hey guys Ryan Wright here and tonight
I'm gonna watch some [ __ ] I'm gonna
watch the official teaser trailer for
The Avengers age of Ultron I'm excited
come on man think about it it's the
[ __ ] Avengers and they're coming back
together with Captain America the Winter
Soldier out now and you already got Thor
two Iron Man 3 and then guardians of the
galaxy oh I don't think are involved in
the Avengers 2 but whatever it's still
really [ __ ] exciting so I'm sure this
trailer is not gonna show us [ __ ] I'm
still excited to see it anyway right
here we go here we go yes
[ __ ] Iron Man
[Music]
the mission sir
give it back
[Music]
remember how great the Avengers was the
team
how badass
oh man
that was an Ironman at the beginning was
it I just made myself look like a damn
idiot
that was pretty [ __ ] sweet though man
oh dude ah you know it probably won't
feel as magical until we're actually in
the theater again yeah really dug the
hell out of that teaser trailer oh I
knew we weren't gonna see anything but
it's cool enough if you're new to the
channel subscribe please
apparently it's become at this point in
the videos where I like to your shout
outs now D&I and so we get te oh dude
I've talked to you several times don't
know how to say your name actually you
are great we had a great conversation
the other day and you're an awesome
human being Indonesia all the way joven
Van Ryn I think is your name you have
the Man of Steel thumbnail anyway dude
thanks for everything
you leave wonderful comments that just
make me extra cocky 95 how's it going
there's any subscriber that loves to
make a good sex show it's 95 at one flip
the numbers 69